if joe biden were to run for president
for a second term yeah it would not be
possible it can't work the first time
around joe biden was calling a lid every
week he was sleeping in his basement or
something to that effect and he could
get away with it with coven but i think
that was the that was the reason he
didn't have to go out but i think i
think you guys are under underestimating
how appealing he is to the american
people
he's a sly devil the way he sounds the
way he speaks wait i get it i've never
like been close to him close enough to
touch his hand uh he smells like the
mung beans or something
you know you know you don't want to be
because ian i got to be honest if if you
were at an event and joe biden saw you
from behind yeah with your long
twitter profile he's like it's corn pop
he's back think about how funny it would
be though like biden would go up behind
ian and then grab his shoulders and go
you're not and then but then ian would
be like yo yo i'm a guy and i would be
like i know i know this
is
your long
okay but in all seriousness
uh in in in 2020 there were a lot of
excuses about why biden should have run
why he could win i didn't buy them
but a lot of people were just they
really hated trump well now a lot of
people really hate joe biden his
approval rating is low it's never been
msnbc is like despite the booming
economy people you know people don't
like joe biden but but
imagine joe biden running again
against who uh that's why i'm like
honestly don't give him trump give him
desantis yes give him the sanchez
because like they they hated trump
because he was trump
people dislike or hate biden because of
what his policies have been doing to
them directly and that right there is
the difference whereas if you had ron
desantis run you get rid of everything
about trump that people hate and now
instead you can focus on the policies
that people loved in florida and people
fled to in mass in florida because they
were trying to get away like i did from
philadelphia of the crazy leftist
policies oh you're in florida now no i'm
over in indiana oh okay so you know what
you know i think about it though
trump should run
because we're at the point now where i'm
pretty sure enough people are gonna look
at biden and trump and go i'm not making
that same mistake twice
and then not only do you get trump back
in office to be the raging bull storming
through the ivy tower but you could say
i told you so to all those people who
turned around and said yeah okay we made
a mistake with that one see i i look at
desantis though because
whether like the whole don't don't say
gay bill which isn't actually a bill
that says parental can't say don't say
gay right um he was smart in the way he
put that bill into place because he is
making the left now
respond in kind to him and say
we want to teach our kids this in school
and your average parent is like you're
teaching what to my k through third
grader no i don't think so whereas trump
would just go out and be like what's the
headline for the day what can i go after
and smash with a hammer and now and now
we have a chance to put something like
jfk a little bit yeah now we have a
chance to put to put um ron desantis in
front where he could have the chance to
lead on policy and get
and get the progressive left to answer
that i i'd i'd rather have desantis to
be completely honest because of what the
new the latest news that he's calling a
special legislative session to the
redistricting uh no for congress uh for
constitutional carry oh okay so wow so
ron desantis was like yeah we're gonna
do a special session come in vote on
everyone being able to carry guns
without permits and you just buy and
conceal and everything and it's just
like you didn't have to do that i
already liked you yeah but i like this a
lot so bring that to the federal
government i'd love to see him be like
as president you know one of my agenda
items for this is uh repealing the nfa
imagine if he came out and he just
issued an executive order a moratorium
on atf action against nfa items
i don't know if you'd go that far
but you know
i
let's tell them to do it yeah
in all honesty ron if you're listening i
mean the cdc called you anything's
possible he's gonna give us a buzz
somebody somebody said i should have
answered the phone as dr faucia
are you wearing your masks
uh my concern with desantis is that the
the media's on a started their smear
campaign against them now with this
don't say gay crap um but it's not that
they haven't done with trump so it's
like not any worse but they tried to do
it with him during kovitt too and and
that yes and it failed like they really
tried to make desantis look like he had
four heads he was gonna kill grandma and
and that the state was gonna burn into
flames and yet that's a good point you
even had aoc partying maskless in
florida right everybody can see that the
progressives and the democrats are being
led
by hypocrites
and liars
yeah i mean you're going to have people
and look the media can propagandize the
public all they want people are decently
intelligent they're going to notice that
the folks living in the states that
everyone is leaving are telling you not
to vote for the guy who ran the state
everyone has been trying to move to and
uh to your point brian ian i would or i
guess to ian's point but bouncing off
what brian said a moment ago you're
correct that the media started a smear
campaign against them with the the um
parental rights and education bill but
all they did was make themselves look
really bad just like the oscars well
they really obnoxious they they
brilliant play from their from the
republicans on this one the parental
rights and education bill says no secret
conversations no withholding medical
information and no uh specific sex ed
kind of talk for kindergarten to third
grade
uh the the initial uh bill on the
website said pre-k but the bill itself
says kindergarten so there's a bit of a
confusion there we were saying pre-k for
a while i checked the actual language of
the bill says kindergarten so that's a
correction but also the floor.gov
website does say pre-k so i don't know
where that where that split is coming
from but imagine now you look at the
tweets like david hogg tweeted this
where he was like here's a quote from
the bill sounds like don't say gay to me
and i'm just like but that quote you
posted also prohibits straight
discussions as well and i'm just like i
don't understand why these people are so
hell-bent on having sex conversations
with children don't say it's a better
name it's such a weird thing to look for
in a bill too you hear there's a
parental rights bill they're like but is
this going to make it more difficult to
have conversations with children in
secret about uh gay sex like we need to
be sure we need to make sure that that's
not the case otherwise it's just a
massive violation of our rights but the
crazy part is
it's not about gay
it's about literally any anything yes
exactly so control you can't you can't
go in florida to a classroom and be like
mommies and daddies love each other and
get married ah nope you can't do that
this bill prevents that and
the people who supported it most people
support it because they're like yeah
that makes sense
that that's big to me though when you
see the polling showing that it's like
what is it 60 some odd percent supported
the parental rights and education bill
with the horrendous framing yep that was
right it means people are starting to
break through the lies which is kind of
why i'd love to see a trump biden
rematch
desantis i think is better in a lot of
ways to be completely honest
but uh he is i mean he's he's younger
he's more in i think he's more in tune
um
this constitutional carry thing that's
just so fantastic but what he's doing
with florida is just wonderful and
people are chatting being like don't
take him away from us in florida yeah
like the but that's actually really
interesting no that's a really
interesting trump can be governor of
florida
first of all i've been judged another
great estate but i mean can you can you
how much better and granted i am not
downplaying the necessity of having the
right person in the oval office but
i do think there is something to be said
for this idea that desantis is really
extremely powerful in florida and
imagine how much better this country
would be if other political leaders just
followed suit and behaved like him in
their states if republican governors in
other parts of the country actually had
some guts and developed a spine and
stood up for their people the way ron
desantis has the country would be so i
mean i think that would do more good for
the country than even the desantis
presidency was god balls yeah is new
york ending the vax mandates now i just
heard that i heard they did yes so
that's that i give it to desantis it's
because of people like him particularly
him that the country has been able to
dodge a proverbial bullet of having to
jab ourselves when now we're we're
acknowledging that you don't really need
it yep so and he goes and i'm
interrupting no no but like this goes
back to and i've been pushing this a lot
in my program
instead of responding to narratives
setting the narratives like and that's
where desantis has been killing it he is
not responding to okay leftist makes a
argument and they're full force and now
conservatives libertarians anybody right
of center is now playing defense instead
desantis is playing offense we're seeing
republicans play offense libertarians
playing offense and now you're seeing
the left scramble because they're not
used to having to actually explain
wait
why do you want to teach kids sex when
they're in kindergarten like that wasn't
happening secret conversations and have
secret conversations with children right
now now and having a fun little
expression like you when you're
explaining you're losing
the left is explaining now and now that
they're in this this trap of having to
unwind this massive web that they have
made of just insanity your average
person and i keep on going back to the
average person i think this is who we
should be talking to they're looking at
what's happening and they're like this
is insane this isn't i don't want teach
my kids sex when they're in kindergarten
like and even if that's a conversation
to have let me have it let me determine
when that's going to be so
all all the more reason why we all like
rhonda santos and what's happening in
florida why so many people are moving
there but uh just in terms of you know
going back to the original subject was
joe biden running we also we need to
consider that
if joe biden can't run for president
that means the democrats need to
announce
in a month or two
that because they're gonna have to start
setting up their primary candidates yep
so 2023 is primary season and if it's
not going to be biden could you imagine
biden trying to campaign he's going to
be 80. yeah so what you're what you're
saying is i need to release all of the
biden cartoons you've been working on
within like the next month or so before
he's gone yeah yeah you're gonna have
like a this really great 12 you know
minute i've been working animation on
biden no i have a 12-part mini series on
him hour-long episode come on
i mean you're biden's singing the
greatest hits got like how many you get
almost to a million eight hundred
thousand
yeah he's a lot of fun he's a lot of fun
it is sad funny you know what i mean
like it's sad
it's dangerous that's the thing like
it's kind of vague i like poke fun at
him i try not to be too cruel um because
on some level it's you feel bad for the
guy his brain just doesn't work but at
the same time it is really hysterical
that everyone is avoiding saying that he
clearly has dementia first they were
saying he
had a stutter now they're saying it's
because he's irish
he says these ridiculous things
he calls for regime change in russia
because he's irish and so he understands
empathy and i'm like is that like a
genetic irish
i don't have i got a brand new shiny
helmet and a pair of kickstarter
i don't have the same kind of sympathy
for this guy because if if you know if
you get behind the wheel of a car for
instance and you're blind and you end up
killing someone i have no sense i hear
you bro i agree with you on that but i
almost think he's to the point where
someone else had to put him there i just
don't know that he's competent enough to
have made the decision to place himself
in that position it's like you have
somebody in the back seat of the car
they're like joe biden in the front seat
they're like all right there's a turn up
here to the left turn turn now turn now
and he's like what where tree and he
just goes off into the ravine but like
whose turn is it no but yeah who turns
in anyways ian i i would i would agree
with you i think my point is more or
less and really what i'm trying to get
at is if this was anyone else if i were
to see any other person experiencing
that kind of cognitive decline it would
just make me it would make me sad i
wouldn't really find much to poke fun at
but because this man is literally the
leader of the country and everyone's
trying to pretend that he's not only fit
but that he's like the best they can't
just claim that he's fit he's like the
best president ever it's a booming
economy according to msnbc why don't
people like him and the man can't finish
a single sentence without saying
something ridiculous or stamina or slur
everyone everyone should imagine the
emperor you know the emperor's new
clothes story and it's the emperor who
ends up walking down the street naked
with everyone pretending like he's not
but now we have social media take that
story like a video
again and replace the emperor with with
biden and not only is the is the emperor
wearing no clothes but he's demented yep
and he's like fumbling about confused
and someone's holding his hand as he
goes
so they're all like nuclear wars coming
russia and everything right and you know
russia's gonna shut off gas and they're
flying planes with nukes on them could
you imagine if
vladimir putin is in his nuclear bunker
and he's like fire missiles
and then nato generals calls and they're
like mr president russia has fired an
icbm towards ukraine should we retaliate
yeah man you know we hit libya you know
take them out and they're like olivia
sir you know come on man and like all
right i guess
you know what biden's first reaction
would be if he heard that news he'd be
like
oh
it would be disappointment because he's
a legend
really that's a 20 man listen listen
when joe biden was talking about syria
back at like the g7 or whatever
he kept calling it libya yep and i'm
like yo people don't people downplay
this when when peter ducey was talk was
asking questions to biden he said
it seemed like you said this and it
seemed like you said this and body's
like never happened it's like biden
you're only lying to yourself because
everyone in the world heard you say it
imagine if he's in private with a
general where should we retaliate uh
libya man it's like libya are you sure
are you sure you heard me it's like okay
the president said nuke libya and then
you're like no no moscow joe
is a journalist gonna pop up and go joe
biden actually meant to say moscow oh
the generals then say oh okay okay we'll
change the trajectory i can't allow you
to spread this paranoid misinformation
joe biden's geriatric nurse would be
there to let the general know he's
having a senior moment and that he
actually means something else do you
think they're sending the man around
without a translator out of your mind
yo i know some old trump is old and he
has spry yeah it's true
the the thing about trump is he wouldn't
accidentally tell you to nuke the wrong
place he'd tell you to hit moscow kind
of early he'd be like i don't want to
deal with it if he's going to nuke it
hit him first he went into ukraine done
it before he invaded like just in case
no i don't think trump would have
actually nuked moscow i'm kidding but
but there's that uncertainty like even
trump was saying five ten percent you
don't you know this guy's kind of crazy
he's like if i budget
a ten percent might have done it like i
might have viewed him i was thinking i'm
not i i was thinking about it i was i
really
i wouldn't was
surprised if he was
or or he just knows how to do the big
ask and he goes to she and he goes to
putin and says do it and i'll nuke you
and joe biden can only just say come on
man come on or no you don't got a soul
that's what he claims he looked putin in
the eye and he told that bully you don't
have a soul as if vladimir putin is just
this really introspective guy who was
like well if joe biden doesn't think i
have soul perhaps is it getting wrong
there's a good cartoon you could make
though where like in biden's mind he's
like ripped and he like walks up to
putin and he's like listen here chum you
ain't got no soul no malarkey and
putin's like oh please mr biden please
and then like in reality he's like
you soul man and then food's like food's
on the horse he called me a soul man
he's like i'm a soul man that's the
thing putin but that's like
so what he told him he's mean you told
the foreign leader he's mean thank you
joe this is why they claim we push
russian propaganda because we're sitting
here making fun of our president acting
like putin is not you know but then he
shouldn't act like an idiot maybe if our
president didn't have dementia we would
be making fun of putin instead and we
made fun of trump too
yeah exactly i mean frankly i was
thinking i thought baby today i will hit
the button no no no think about it it's
just a thought i didn't say i would do
it uh yeah you mentioned something
earlier because you were saying that
biden will simply say i didn't say that
man yeah even though everyone knows you
did it's on camera you made a point
earlier about how that could just be
an issue with members of his generation
they don't expect everything to be
filmed they don't i mean i find with
most public personalities under the age
of 40 when someone calls them out for
something they said they're usually
embarrassed about it or they start to
offer an explanation they won't say i
never said that if i truly you're on to
something didn't know that i said if
someone said you said something and i'm
like no i i don't think so yes you did
i'd be like okay show me the footage so
i can verify that you're right here and
i would eat it you do have to what are
you gonna do i'm not gonna lie to people
yeah but this it's it's not it's just
that joke but
you'd show joe biden in the video and
he'd be like what am i looking at he'd
be trying to like look at it and
everything and then be like joe
this is you saying you would use
chemical weapons and he goes
what no i never said that that's not me
he's gonna go no man that's a decree
a pancake man which one of them they put
your face on it a deep cake
cake man i didn't say that
i'm still gonna make fun of joe biden
after he's president too that's for sure
well no i mean maybe he'll be less
relevant the left ripped on reagan
decades after he left office and i
remember this joke
they said it over and over again oh how
hilarious how stupid that the
republicans had a president who was
experiencing cognitive decline it's like
you guys shows yeah exactly it's like
well you guys
that was georgia's presidency you guys
chose joe biden knowing he was demented
he wasn't president like there was an
out
and you still picked him
yo man that that's how i uh have you see
you guys see the story that uh um
the army is uh uh reducing its uh
enlistment expectations yes yes because
like the commercial about having two
moms didn't work
exactly well actually let me see if i
can find it you know so uh but anyway my
point is kind of wrapping up the joe
biden thing
uh i forgot where i was going with it
because now i want to talk about the the
oh i i heard that it's because of the
botched afghanistan surrender let's call
it a surrender because that's what it
was we surrendered all 800 billion worth
of equipment to the enemy um and hastily
left a bunch of people there
that that's the reason people are not
signing up for the military now because
they don't trust it thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there